el granjero jose cultiva vegetales y
divide su campo entre cultivos de
brócoli y cultivos de espinaca el año
pasado cosechó 6 toneladas de brócoli
por acre 6 toneladas de brócoli por acre
y nueve toneladas de espinaca por acre
que dieron un total de 93 toneladas de
vegetales este año cosechó 2 toneladas
de brócoli por acre y tres toneladas de
espinaca por acre para un total de 31
toneladas de vegetales cuántos acres de
cultivo de brócoli y cuántos acres de
cultivo de espinacas tiene el granjero
jose vamos a analizarlo bueno vamos a
definir los acres de cultivo de brócoli
con la variable be y los acres de
cultivo de espinaca vamos a llamarlos él
y bueno cuántos cultivos de brócoli tuvo
el año pasado vamos a notar
el año pasado
año pasado
no dicen que él cosechó 6 toneladas de
brócoli por acre así que esto fue el año
pasado cosechó 6 toneladas de brócoli
por acre y él tiene b acres de cultivo
pues entonces el año pasado él cosechó 6
toneladas por cada acre y tiene b acres
de cultivo de cultivo de brócoli y
siguiendo la misma lógica cuántas
toneladas de espinaca cultivo bueno
tenía nueve toneladas de espinaca por
acre y tiene acres de espinaca así que
va a ser más
9 toneladas por acre por el número de
acres así que la suma de estos dos es
igual a 93 toneladas de vegetales y esto
fue el año pasado ahora este año
este año
que tenemos bueno nos dice que ahora
tiene dos toneladas de brócoli por acre
son dos toneladas por acre y tiene b
acres entonces son dos por b toneladas
de brócoli más ahora nos dicen que
cultivo tres toneladas de espinaca por
acre son tres toneladas de espinaca por
el número de acres dedicados a las
espinacas tres por él y esto va a ser
igual a las 31 toneladas de vegetales de
este año esto es igual a 31 recordemos
ese 93 eran las 93 toneladas de
vegetales del año pasado
la forma de resolver este tipo de
problemas es establecer variables para
las cosas que nos preguntan y analizar
la información que nos dan para
organizar estas variables y poder
encontrar lo que nos piden por ejemplo
aquí estamos suponiendo que siempre va a
tener el mismo número de acres de
cultivo de brócoli y que también siempre
va a tener el número de acres dedicados
al cultivo de espinacas
y ahora tenemos un sistema de ecuaciones
con los que podemos encontrar los
valores de b y de bueno que variable
vamos a despejar primero permítanme
reescribir esta primera ecuación aquí
tenemos seis b más
y esto es igual a 93
yo creo que nos conviene ahorita
eliminar las veces por lo que vamos a
multiplicar esta segunda ecuación por
menos 3 en ambos lados aquí también
multiplicamos por menos 3 y que nos
queda menos 3 por 2 b va a ser igual a
menos 6 b menos 3 por 3 que va a ser
igual a menos 3 por 39
aquí de este lado nos queda 31 x menos 3
igual a menos 3 por 13 3 por 3 993 si
hacemos la operación nos va a dar que 6
b menos 6 b es 0
9 - 9 también es cero aquí tenemos 0 y 0
es igual a 93-93 pues ser es igual a 0 y
sabemos que esto se va a cumplir pero es
igual a 0 sin importar qué valores
tengamos debe o de así que tenemos que
ese es un problema con un número
infinito de soluciones número infinito
infinito d
soluciones
soluciones estas restricciones no nos
están dando la información suficiente
como para dar un valor fijo a ve ya hay
infinitas combinaciones de valores para
ver y que satisfacen esto entonces no
tenemos suficiente información para dar
un valor a b y a aquí lo ponemos con
signos de exclamación para indicar que
es importante no hay
no hay suficiente
suficiente
información
no hay suficiente información lo
resaltamos